On February 2nd 2010 the US Treasury
estimated the national debt at one point
to two seven eight times 10 to the 13th
power and just to get a sense of things
10 to the 6th you're talking of 1 times
10 to the 6 is a million 1 times 10 to
the 9th is a billion 1 times 10 to the
12th is a trillion so we're talking
about on the order of magnitude of 10
trillion dollar so this is about 12
trillion dollars then they tell us that
the US Census Bureau estimate for the US
population was about three point zero
eight six times 10 to the 8th power so
this is a little over 300 million people
so that's an interesting number right
there it's a population and then they
say using these estimates calculate the
per person share of the national debt so
essentially we want to take the entire
debt and divide by the number of people
that'll give us the per person share of
the national debt use scientific
notation to make your calculations and
express your answer in both scientific
and decimal notations all right which
means just as a regular number round to
four decimal places while making
calculations so we want the per person
debt so we wanna take the total debt
divided by the number of people so the
total debt is 1.2 to 7 8 times 10 to the
13th power and we want to divide that by
the total number of people the total
number of people which is three point
zero eight six times 10 to the 8th and
we could separate this into two division
problems we could say that this is equal
to the division right here these guys
1.2 2 7 8 / 3.06 so 1.2 - 7 8 divided by
three point zero eight six and then x
times 10 to the 13th divided by 10 to
the 8th now what's 10 to the 13th
divided by 10 to the 8th let me do it
over here 10 to the 13th over 10 to the
8th the way I think about it this is the
exact same thing this is equal to 10 to
the
13 times 10 to the negative 8 right 1
over this is an 8 right here if you have
a 10 to the 8 in the denominator that's
like multiplying by 10 to the negative 8
so you have 13 you have the same base 10
so 10 to the 13th times 10 to the
negative 8 is going to be 10 to the 13
minus 8 which is 10 to the 5th or
another way to think about it use if you
have if you have the base in the
denominator you subtract the exponent so
it's 13 minus 8 10 to the fifth so it's
this blue expression times 10 to the 5th
10 to the 13th divided by 10 to the 8th
is 10 to the 5th 10 to the 5th power and
let's get a calculator out to calculate
this right here let's get the calculator
out and they say round everything to 4
decimal places so I'll keep that in mind
turn my calculator on one point two two
seven eight divided by three point zero
no three point zero eight six is equal
to three let's see how many three nine
seven nine because we want to round
right there four digits so three nine
seven nine let me remember that let me
just put it on the side you put on the
eye side so I can still look at it so
this this little dividing decimals
problem results in this is zero zero
point three nine seven nine and of
course times 10 to the fifth times 10 to
the fifth dollars per person now once
again you might be tempted to say hey
this is in scientific notation I have
some number times a power of 10 but
notice this number is not greater than
or equal to 1 remember this number if
you want to be formal about scientific
notation has to be greater than or equal
to 1 or less than 10 so what we can do
here is we can multiply lets if we don't
want to change the number we can
multiply this number by 10 and divide
this number by 10 or another way you can
think about it is this whole thing can
be rewritten as 0.397 9 times 10
times 10 to the 4th times 10 to the 4th
what I did just now is I broke up the 10
to the 5th into a 10 and a 10 to the 4
and 10 to the 4th and I did that because
I want to multiply this by 10 so I can
get a 3 out front instead of a 0.3 so
let's do that so if you multiply this
out so essentially I took a 10 out of
the 10 to the 5th I divided it by 10 and
I multiplied this other guy by 10 not
changing the whole number so then this
right here will become 3 point 9 7 9 and
then times 10 to the 4th times times 10
to the 4th power so that's how much debt
there is per person in scientific
notation so this is debt per person in
scientific notation now in the problem
they also wanted to wanted us to express
it in decimal notation decimal notation
which is just kind of standard you know
writing it as a number with our standard
numeric decimal system so what is 3
point 9 7 9 times 10 to the 4 so let's
think about it
we have 3 point 9 7 9 times 10 to the
4th well let me just do it this way
times 10 to the 4th so if we multiply it
let's just move the decimal space if we
multiply it by 10 we're going to get
thirty nine point seven nine if we
multiply it by 10 squared we're going to
three hundred ninety seven point nine if
we multiply 10 to the third we're going
to get 3979 if we multiply it by 10 to
the fourth we're going to get one more
zero right there so we're essentially
going to move the decimal four to the
right and we get it's 39 so I could
write it like this this is equal to 39
thousand seven hundred and ninety
dollars so if you think about the
national debt per person every man woman
and child in the United States
essentially owes thirty nine thousand
dollars
seven hundred or thirty nine thousand
seven hundred and ninety dollars